When it's time to celebrate, we do it together.
Yeah,
and when it's time to eat, we stay close to our plates.
(laughing)
And I don't do anything without
the best date in town, Ross Matthews.
(audience cheering)
But you can't have an Emmy party without something to eat.
I mean, right?
All right, so here to present some spectacular snacks
and sips is a woman I love so much.
I actually wrote a cookbook with her.
That's right.
It comes out in November.
It's called "Rebel Homemaker,"
and I think we are rebel homemakers.
It's Chef Pilar Valdes.
(audience cheering)
Now, Pilar,
you have a real knack for pairing food
with the nominees and coming up with a pithy pun.
So, I'm going to let you take it away.
What's our first one?
All right.
So, today we have four bites inspired by the nominees.
First step, we have Kate Winslettuce cups.
(audience laughing)
So here, we have this wonderful bite.
It's inspired by a Thai pork dish,
but you could actually use a ground chicken
or ground turkey,
or if you want to keep it vegetarian,
you could also do mushroom or cauliflower.
You get the crunch from the lettuce,
a lot of savoriness from the pork,
and then a ton of herbs and a little bit of chili.
The flavor in that one bite.
(audience cheers)
All that herb, the chili.
And is it healthy?
It is, it actually really is.
God, I love this!
(laughter)
We want it to be that show that wasn't like--
Literally--
(laughter)
(audience cheering)
You know it's good when everybody gets quiet.
Yes, exactly.
That makes the cook happy.
I am very, very happy.
Shall we move on?
Yes.
Okay, so next up, in honor of one of the nominees,
the dish is Jason Sudeggkis.
(laughing)
It's a deviled egg,
very classic,
but with a little bit of a spin.
I like to put a little bit of hot sauce
and a little bit of pickled brine in my deviled eggs.
Ooh, smart!
Mm-hmm. Shall we?
This is Egg Lasso.
There you go!
(laughing)
I like to do a little topping bar.
So if you have people over,
you can do a little bacon bits,
you can do a little toasted breadcrumbs,
you could do more pickles,
and then have it be like
a choose your own adventure kind of thing.
I love that.
You guys hear that?
A topping bar for deviled eggs.
I've never been happier, Pilar.
That is the most brilliant--
(Pilar laughs)
I have one thing to say to that.
(laughing)
You're going to hate the next one. Go on.
They can definitely mix. I'm like,
"Ooh, it's so good."
Oh my God.
(laughing)
All right. So, how are we doing guys?
I'm not even listening.
I'm just eating. Sorry.
(laughing)
I'm going to,
I'm going to roll in and move on to the next.
The next thing we have is Issa Crudi-rae.
I love this.
Issa-- Wait, say it again.
Issa Crudi-rae.
Okay, I see what you did.
Coup d'etat, crudi-rae. Okay.
That's so good.
You were selling that when you were a little insecure.
(laughing)
You!
(chuckling)
I'm like stupid.
Where do I go from that?
(laughing)
So this one, Drew,
takes another of your loves of French onion soup.
We made it into a French onion dip.
Caramelized onions,
Worcestershire sauce,
hot paprika,
and then it's in a creamy base.
It's really good.
We lightened it up.
We actually use Greek yogurt instead of like,
the heavier stuff.
You guys.
This is so good.
I mean, look how good that is.
And I love that they're also served in little cups.
You can also put it on a platter if you'd like,
but put it in a cup.
This is all me.
(laughing)
Listen, you could put potato chips with this.
Oh yeah.
And I will.
Yeah. Uh-huh.
Yes, a hundred percent. Okay.
Last up.
You guys ready?
Yes.
In honor of the TV show, "This Is Us,"
we have "This is Truffs."
(audience laughing)
We have some beautiful, decadent, chocolate truffles.
Everyone thinks, "Oh my God, truffles. They're so fancy."
No, they're really dead simple to make.
You just have a ganache,
which has equal parts melted chocolate and cream,
scoop it out with an ice cream scoop
and then you roll it in additional melted chocolate.
So it has like--
I understand why you love Pilar, now.
(Pilar laughs)
When you were just saying, like,
"I really love her,"
I was like, "Yeah, yeah, yeah."
No, I get it.
I think I really love her right now.
I just had a whole moment.
Oh, I'm so glad.
I had a complete moment over here.
(laughing)
I mean, chocolate and chocolate.
With the little salt.
Yes. So again, like taking the same idea from the,
the deviled egg bar, you can roll it in multiple things.
You could do it with sea salt
or just have a side of pomegranate.
Hello, lover.
Ooh, pomegranate!
Yeah.
Ross, I'm going to need you to take us into break.
(laughing)
I got your back.
Let's hear it for Chef Pilar!
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much.
And head over to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
for the full recipes.
You're going to want to make this during the show.